are let's talk about the environment
there were two studies released this
week announcing that
a large a sheet in West and Arctica is
beginning to melt which
might start the process at sea level
rising not good
we got a bit make Korea so this study
from the University of Washington
concluded that the collapse
a the wat glacier is already underway
this process could be completed within
the next few centuries
and would cause the ocean to rise by
nearly 2 beat
a because that closure is currently
acting as a barrier
for the rest of the ice sheet its
collapse could ultimately trigger attend
13-foot rise in global sea levels we've
got some info from unnecessary also
this study predicted a poor fit right in
fee levels as the melting rate
accelerate in the amended
the sector when the antarctic are
pulling warm water to the servicing
causing the ice to melt
global warming is a contributing factor
but not the sole cause natural 9
human-induced changes in climate across
the globe
might also be at fault so I want to
start with that part
I'm gonna go to our science and green
person birth
so what they're basically saying here is
that this is a combo
the man-made climate change and that
things are just
changing on earth just because a natural
process these
is that accepted in the scientific
community at this point that there's two
things happening here
yeah I would something where are you
know when you get down into the new one
survey studies they're talking about
you know there is the natural processes
you know the natural oscillations that
the
ocean currents and winds go through in
global temperatures you know but there's
also than that human-induced
influence that kicks it up a notch so
what that's kinda what world do you
believe in climate change is that weird
I accept the science of climate change
ok absolutely i diritti
I but you know what what what i think is
most shocking about this is is part of
it
is your definition of collapse you know
when when the public the general public
hears the word collapse they think oh my
god it's going right now
and when they're talking about it in
science terms in this specific thing
with with glaciers are talking about
you know there is a point after which it
is not ever going to week
returned irreversible and it will lead
to the eventual collapse
you know so there is a scientifically
it's more of a slow collapse obviously
it's gonna take
you know they estimate about two hundred
years or so
at the minimum for this specific glacier
that way to Glacier to
to melt and that is going to then be the
issue with the West Antarctic ice sheet
which is you know massive
yeah it's a cover stuff that cotton and
and that's something I hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of years but it's
still going to be
very important for all coastal city am I
making this up it's something like 20
times the size of Manhattan
I'm yeah it's huge I mean when you
realize Antarctica is a cotton
an actual cotton and I forget how big it
is in comparison to say the North
American continent by
it is it is darn huge is going to be a
problem you know when
you know we're not just talking about
this specific glacier been the only one
that melting it just happens to be the
one they looked at in this particular
study that's nothing quite quickly
we have glaciers melting all over the
world and we have Greenland I smelled as
well so
all these together cumulatively are
going to raise sea levels as well
and there's really a when it's when you
get to this irreversible place you know
they're saying
we don't see any way that these ice
sheets are going to be stop there's no
mountain range yanni
there there's nothing to stop it so is
part about this just happened so slowly
as there's anything I think that sorta
we we deal with things especially our
politicians we don't deal with
issues have today so we definitely are a
good deal with issues
up tomorrow who's part is that it's just
happening so slowly
that one day it's just gonna keep rising
keep right here and then we'll just be
swimming ever although I we always plan
because I remember I didn't swim
waterworld
really be more like actual history yeah
I'm
I think that yeah you know it
unfortunately maybe the clock for the
climate change
I science be it has been
so sort of hijacked as a political
I'm to all the time when people see it
even if there is science behind it or
or whatever they're they're very quick
to say I
know this is definitely have somebody
using it to trump up some kind of agenda
and I think that's unfortunate because
indeed
you know we have seen so much evidence
come out to say that you know there is a
certain point where
we are doing things that are harmful to
the to the car the country just
just a man dressed in a red yeah but
everybody out now I'm
to the world I however on that no I did
look at some other sea levels if you
look at Los Angeles in a hundred years
if we are two years or so
we have a 10-foot increase in sea levels
the only people who will be affected
are those living in rented already let's
be honest yeah
and you really wanted to get there that
yeah I could see her I could take a
is part of this so II obviously believed
in climate aid I believe these things
are happening
but is part of this disorder what human
evolution is all about like were gonna
destroy this
for I i feel like it's just sort of the
way
evolution is richer than they were gonna
go somewhere else and that's why we're
exploring space because everyone knows
we're gonna do that was a couple
different things if i may forget all I
would
I would I recommend that you say I
accept the science because I can say I
believe in climate
YouTube right between the eyes their
religion and you know and that's
bullshit and that's not what we're
talking about we're talking about you
except the signs are you not exile amid
the right now I accept the science
area in the early phase you I
but then I it when it comes to human
nature I think you are absolutely right
that there is a part of the evolution
you know where essentially
species and you know obviously where
that their the most advanced sentient
species that's what the earth by
previously
Mather or more than 10 let's just say
that
yeah we can actually think about what
we're doing unlike you know most most
species
and what tends to happen in nature is
that a species will expand into its
territory and expanded
to its range in till it uses up all the
resources and you know once it uses up
all the resources nature has a pretty
you know swift and efficient way of
cutting that species back to size limits
with then
it's a in my room and so we're kinda
following along with that same
natural progression we do have the
choice though
you can anytime stopped at nothing you
know that's the whole point of Sciences
you know using science to be able to
predict
stuff otherwise why bother yeah do you
think site is having a little bit of a
comeback right now I think as most I'm
Brock said with getting some good but
there is a sense
%uh like we need to be a little more
scientifically literate this country
then
stories like this right I think sort of
problems that are hard to come back
yeah I mean I think a science
for whatever reason has like this really
bad rap yeah I
in which is really strange because
everything we hold
get it seems it seems so obvious now I
think again thing
I certainly hope so you know as a as a
child science
I'm I I'm out it is definitely
more popular now than it used to be not
just with causes but you know that they
spoke a I fucking love science yeah
as people you know I with CSI the TV
show people sir got interested in the
science science you know and yeah
thats popularizing the concept of
Sciences popularizing the ideas in the
scientific method and I think with bad
comes more engagement from the public
although we know we do have a problem
with a very strong a
effort culturally by a certain you know
a group with evangelical right-wingers
who insist that you know we have to
include religion in our science classes
and you know we've had two
beat back that particular onslaught
periodically since the twenties
so that's the part that errors and this
will be the final thought on this like
the part
these people that simply don't believe
in the evidence I don't get what they're
paid
has to do with this why can't you have
paid in
Higher Being or whatever your religious
beliefs are and still believe that
humans
are doing quieter that alot ending I i
really think that it comes down to
skepticism based on on what I just
talking earlier which is there
there are people who use it for agenda I
you no point making when you are the
opposite side of that
if your conservative you see man-made
climate change historically being an
issue
a that is sorta on champion by the left
and downplayed by the right so it's not
even about whether or not it's real or
not it's about
this is a this is something that
somebody else says
on on my opposing team so I mean I'm
gonna disagree
yet about the endless bi polar Hitz
everything we got into your tribal
identity I mean people have a cultural
identity and I tend to filter the news
and any other information they get
through that cultural identity
and so it doesn't fit with that cultural
identity then they rejected
although I will say they're are
evangelical Christian Scientist
you know there's a climate scientist
named Catherine hey ho was doing a great
job trying to
I know I says the most adorable plant
sciences that has ever yes the
she's the cutest thing and she also is
able to
Serbian ambassador of science to these
religious groups and say
hey you know you don't have to believe
that the world is more than 6,000 years
old and
order to understand Physics you know you
can say that hey God created the world
he might also have created physics yeah
and so we're just figure it out way so
we don't have to just get to a place
where we can agree that like
we don't know everything science and
explain everything in religion certainly
can't
different right any we cannot get to
that place but we've got a bite